شعور القلقي يتزايد لدى كبار السن في
بريطانيا بشان تاثير ازمه ارتفاع كلفه
المعيشه
ميشيل المتقاعده حديثا تواجه ضغطا كبيرا
لتغطيه الزيادات الضخمه في الاسعار ما
ارغمها على اتباع نهج تقش فيه عبر مراجعه
قوائم الضروريه والاستغناء عن الكثير من
الكماليات سامري
ذلك لذا ففي الاشهر القليله الماضيه تغيرت
حياتي كثيرا تخلصت من سيارتي ومصارفها من
بنزين وتكاليف المواقف والصيانه واجرت
غرفه لخمس سنوات لانني بحاجه الى دخل
اضافي لراتب تقاعدي ميشال تحاول التامين
اكبر قدر ممكن من مستلزمات معيشتها
الاساسيه في ظل صعود اسعار الكهرباء
والغاز وغيرها من السلع كما ان نسبه
التضخم الاعلام منذ اربعه عقود الى جانب
ارتفاعه كلفه الاقتراض كلها عوامل اثرت
على قوه الشرائيه مع التراجع قيمه معاشها
التقاعدي الى جانبي مبيعات اعمالنا الفنيه
ومنحوثاتها عام السمر
لكن لا يمكنني تحمل تكلفه تذكره مسرح الان
وارخصها احيانا 35 جنيها وهذا كثير
بالنسبه لي اشاهد نتفليكس وغيرها من
البرامج بدلا من الذهاب لتناول الطعام مع
الاصدقاء انهم مجرد جنون اما مشتريات
الشهريه فهي المزيد من الخضار والعدس
واصبحت اكثر ابداعا في الطهي لمواجهه غلاء
المعيشه
تزيد اعمارهم عن 60 عاما ويعانون من
الشعور بالوحده ودخل محدود
لشراء المستلزمات الضروريه بحسب استطلاعيه
الحديث ما دفع الى التخلي عن ضروريات
اليوميه الى جانب انشطه ترفيهيه واجتماعيه
تخرجهم من العزله والوحده وتحسن حالتهم
الصحيه والذهنيه والنفسيه مصطفى زارو
العربيه